after a special countdown and a few
leaks obsidian officially revealed
pillars of eternity to dead fire and
it's already hit its crowdfunding goal
I'm Tony and this is your super
successful GameSpot news update pillars
of eternity too is inspired by the likes
of Baldur's Gate 2 and planescape
torment and it aims to deliver quote
truly living cities and more freedom to
explore the open world the first game
was funded through Kickstarter and the
sequel was promoted through fig and it
hit its 1.1 million dollar goal in just
under a day with over 10,000 backers
pledging their support the first game
hit 4.1 million when all was said and
done so don't be surprised to see the
numbers go even higher this time with
four weeks left to go pillars of
eternity too is slated for q1 2018 and
it'll be headed to pc mac and linux keep
an eye on gamespot for more info as it
goes through development and to keep up
with all the latest PC gaming news
you're already in the right place